this video is sponsored by Red Shadow
Legends my personal favorite mobile game
out there raid Shadow Legends is a
turn-based MMO RPG game it lets you game
against your friends and thousands of
other players online you can download
the game using the link in the
description of this video raid Shadow
Legend sent us around collecting and
upgrading Champions you want to find
Champions that can work together that
help make winning fights a bit easier
I've been using and leveling up my robot
which is basically an oak if you're
wondering what's an old carrier you see
well get the game you'll find out he's
got a very strong default attack which
really helps when you're just getting
started my go-to is a direct star what's
up
uh you're stupid because it's a demon
he's got a crazy amount of health
because of course demons are fairly
healthy which means he can get away with
taking a lot of damage in the game and
he has this ability which drains any
attack as hell if they try and go for
him and let me tell you this focusing on
defense will me a lot of fights I'm like
the Floyd Mayweather of well that's more
karate but you get the point of their
raid so make sure you use the link in
the video description below if you do
and you're a new player you'll get a
free starter pack which is worth thirty
dollars which will really help you when
starting out on the game however it's
only valid for the next 30 days so don't
wait thanks to raid Shadow Legends for
sponsoring us but for now enjoy the
video
[Music]
at one time I was homeless instead of
going home every night there was no home
to go to life at home was very difficult
I grew up being abused
I lost my belt I lost respect I
embarrassed my family I think it was
pretty much non-existent I was able to
just about scrape by the medicals
I'm gonna come out I have Supreme
confidence and I'm scared to death
afraid of that victim I didn't care
about living I just wanted to die I got
up and I felt the way to the world was
lifted off my shoulders I knew I was
going to make a comeback
fighting this was designed for me this
is what makes us who we are
all right so far ahead of this game
my dream my vision for myself is to be
the greatest martial artist to ever live
I I've always been a fighter there's
nothing I do better than just laughing
fighting there ain't never been a lot
like that to me I was born to do this
I'm the best fighter in the world I'm
the most brutal and ambitious
welcome back to the pain game podcast I
know it's been a while I've been a busy
lad give us a break uh but the day we
have a special guest it is a UFC Hall of
Fame octagon Warrior it is Michael the
count this thing and we are watching two
of his greatest ever performances me and
Mike sit down and watch Anderson Silva
versus Michael Bisping and Luke rockhold
versus Michael Bisping just back-to-back
fights that he put on that were
unbelievable a lot of you know Mike is a
hero to me and uh one of my favorite
people to interview and hang out with
he's just such a good blog good laugh
and I hope you enjoy this podcast
actually the first thing I want to show
you is two girls one cope Jesus Brian
check this out right wow 22nd of
September 2009 top comment this thing is
the Pioneer for British MMA I'm proud of
him hope to meet him one day 12 years
ago years ago
I'm making dreams come true
[Applause]
I don't even remember that interview at
all I thought you were probably hungover
I probably was let's be honest back in
the old days you know what I mean yeah
I'm fighting that um on the 14th of
November I'm fighting Dennis Kang at the
men what am I wearing what am I wearing
going for that bad boy look that was
when Affliction and that were all around
yeah see the echo I was sponsored by
Echo so I got the echo t-shirt on I
think that's an echo jacket as well it
looks like it's made of plastic people
call me a casual I'm like I got a point
in the show oh man you're a hardcore
come on come on the knowledge here he
comes there it is my God that takes me
back there's Daz Perillo Brady at the
back Scott and I'll show the
conditioning coach this was it like make
a break wasn't it to get the world title
fight yeah for me this was my world
title fight at that point I think I'd
given up on you know I've not given up
but I I kind of resigned myself to the
fact that it wasn't going to happen do
you know what I mean because I was near
the end of my career I had one bloody
eye that was keeping secret and I
thought oh I'm probably not gonna get it
and that's okay I'm still having a good
career I've still made some money I've
still had some great fights and uh but
this fight here is one you know I
treated it I'm a world title fight I
always wanted to fight Anderson he'd
only been beaten by Chris Wyman at this
point she was still very much in his
prime yeah bollocks you know it's Ultra
Arena Anderson Silva greatest of all
time as I said for me this was a world
title fight the biggest fight of your
career in my head at that point without
question you know I mean certainly
Anderson Silva I mean come on he was
Anderson Silva and this was six years
ago as well and you know the ultramarine
is such an iconic venue I've got such
great memories fighting uh this fight I
mean I was the most disciplined in any
training camp I've ever been I mean I
had to anyway when the eye injury came
about for that I had to compensate in
every other way being as fit as I could
being as prepared as I could you know
because obviously I was always going to
be at a deficit when it comes to vision
and seeing this is the modest thing
about it though is when when I watched
this fight I never would have known yeah
it was a great Camp I felt good
uh see I always did that walking in that
because the people of England I was
supporting my career so much and I'll
never forget that and I know it sounds
like I'm just trying to say the right
thing and whatnot but yeah spraying the
water on the cameras there for anyone
that doesn't know because that canvas
the blue Parts is really slippy that's
why you see a lot of people yeah it's
slippery so when you put the water down
it just adds a bit of traction I can't
believe that that seems like the worst
possible setup it's very slippy it's
crazy so what I used to do is I'm sure
I'm not the only one the sponsored logos
they have a lot of traction they
actually feel like sandpaper so I so I
would always try and be on them Parts
because you got more attraction and
there he is what's the intimidation
level right now for you you didn't
really fight them like I would have
expected you to I thought you would have
been a lot more intimidated you didn't
overly respect them you got it just
right in that like you give them that
respect yep in order to not let yourself
get in a position of like oh [__] I'm
getting caught here but you didn't give
him too much respect the way you could
just bully you like it does everyone
else psychologically you know but the
whole time I was income that was kind of
the approach and that's why I talked a
lot of [__] I mean listen he did take
steroids but I used that and I made a
much bigger deal out of it uh to strip
him down because I was such a fan of
this guy he inspired me you know what I
mean I loved watching him fight I never
missed a fight and I wanted to fight
because I thought I had the style to
beat him but if I allowed myself to look
at him as the great Anderson Silva that
would affect my performance you know the
Mind controls everything you know and
then confidence is key for a fighter I
had to like strip down all his accolades
and his achievements and just put it
down to steroids and whatnot and then we
knew he would play a lot of Mind Games
in the fight you know he puts his hands
down by the fence and [__] I was like
when he does that stuff I'm not going to
engage but you're in the intimidation I
mean I mean listen you know you are
fighting Anderson I I know at this
moment in time you can see it on my face
I know I'm about to engage in a very
tough fight you know you know that you
have to leave a piece of yourself beside
the Octagon I left several pieces
probably a few bits of my nose in there
as well man this takes me back it really
does people always said do you miss it
and I said no but sitting here watching
this I do because I don't watch my own
fights you know you see a few Clips here
and there but I've never watched it with
like the walkouts and stuff like that we
miss it as well as much as we we've got
some great prospects in like Tom and
Paddy you defined the UK it was like the
guy you know what I mean like our guy so
it does feel like there's a void there
and I don't think anyone's filled that
yet and that's no disrespect that Darren
Taylor or any of that yeah it's just you
had such a successful run where you were
constantly there or thereabouts whereas
you know right now we just haven't quite
got that I think Tom might be there
what's that point do you know what do
you know what right there I said good
luck to him I said [__] good luck but
what I meant was listen we're we're
engaging in a martial arts contest here
all the [__] that I talked and you know
I have nothing but respect for the guy
to be honest and it's like good luck I
mean listen I'm gonna try and [__]
kill you you're gonna try and kill me
but hopefully at the end of this we both
get out of this without long life
brain damage you know what I'm saying
that's why I actually said good luck
[__] good luck I thought that you're
striking and this was unbelievably good
your judgment of distance your footwork
and the way you were just on the edge
all the time so that you couldn't relax
keeping them thinking keeping them
guessing you really led the dance here
well thank you thank you I mean I had to
be the aggressor because with Anderson
you've got to pressure him you know
you've got to try and put him on his
back foot but of course you can't rush
in and be Reckless because he's gonna
catch you but you see I'm trying to
slowly Corral him up against the fence
but he's a Sly old dog you close the
distance fast as well yeah that's
another thing I don't think he was
expecting it to be quite as quick as you
were in this fight you were the quicker
guy you know I think stamina was always
what I thought about when I thought of
your attributes yeah but in this fight
felt like you beat him to the punch
quite a lot actually yeah no I think I
did you know I mean I a lot of the time
I was going first I mean as the fight
progressed I think in round five he
turned on the pressure and he got some
good ones but here we're still still
trying to find our range finally just
got one in there the thing is in the
opening round and against Anderson there
is a lot of hesitation because it's
probably that is most dangerous in the
first round I would imagine he he is but
then also you know you've seen him pull
out these wild Knockouts these wild
stuff which is these unorthodox
techniques you're like you gotta be
careful I felt like perillo's training
was really paying off for you at this
point yeah 100 it takes time you know
but yeah no for sure he definitely
cleaned up my box he cleaned up my
footwork you know made sure I was always
on balance and stuff like that main
thing that Jason did though was was the
psychological side of it like you know
we'd have training sessions and you know
we would work hard all the rest of it
but a lot of the best work was done when
we were just sitting on our asses
afterwards I'd be stretching and sitting
in a pool of sweat and uh just talk
about the fight talk about mindset talk
about psychology of the fight and you
know all those type of things [__]
know the way you close the distance it
was great in and out I mean that's the
thing you've got to be all the way in or
all the way out you can't stand in that
middle range with Anderson he's a
[__] massive middleweight as well he
[__] is he's big he's very very big
but is he in here recently he's a giant
of a middleware yeah I know he is I met
Darren till about within the last year
and I looked at Izzy and I thought I
can't believe you used to her in the
same way class like Darren looks like a
well-aware computer is he yeah he's very
thin now oh absolutely but but then long
limbs the long limbs they're so useful
in mixed martial arts whether you're
grappling whether you're trying to stop
a takedown and of course on the feet in
terms of range and reach things like
that all these fans are fantastic it's
you're not giving him a second like
because the onesie look great against
the Stefan Bonners the forest Griffins a
bit more slower plodding you know you're
constantly keeping them guessing yeah
you see that the heads movie comes with
the shoulders are going because that's
what you're going to do you got to keep
him guessing he can't time you that way
no because then you can land the but
when you decide to throw I just clipped
it now goes come on I'm like will you
[__] come on yeah got a good marble
coming up in a minute a dropping kind of
oh yeah do you know I watch this when
I'm on the treadmill oh really
thank you very much you're just staying
right in the perfect range for them
I love the little touch of the night
it's cool is that come on mate you're
having a laugh on your best man
oh beautiful
as well oh yeah I think he really hurt
him here actually yeah I thought I did
yeah but then look at this he comes oh
give me a hug bless you
until this is done you're my enemy yeah
I said good look at the start I want to
go get that afterwards but until this is
done ain't no [__] hugging mate I
thought that was a huge moment for your
own confidence in the face when in that
first round got a build on that yeah
yeah no absolutely because it shows hold
on first round I can complete I'm faster
I won that round you know what I mean I
landed more shots almost dropped him
there at the end he had to put his hand
down I don't think he realized how good
you were until it was too late almost
and he was two rounds down yeah yeah I I
I don't necessarily disagree with that
you can see he's got a different looking
design now he's like all right hold on a
minute I I gotta come alive he's trying
to do the and now I'm trying yeah he's
like yeah okay I'll let you have that
one but now get ready it's always tricky
when you fight a southpaw Orthodox
versus that whole foot battle and the
lead hand because it takes away so many
of your regular shots you know Jabs are
not ineffective but they're harder to
use yeah but I'm sort of left-hand
dominant that I still managed to pull it
off but trying as good it was it
Filipino boxing whatever beautiful this
is where he just stands there puts his
hands down and we talk we prepared for
this I'm like I'm not gonna do this I'm
not just that it's embarrassing I'm not
gonna he's got great head movement I'm
not going to stand there and try and
fight a guy like that you know what I
mean because he's just making a dick out
of me if I miss yeah you know what I
mean I'm like all right well [__] you
then we can both do that all right let's
go I think you played that perfectly
yeah I said hold on a minute you're not
dictating you're not playing mind games
with me he's trying to boss you around
that's what he's trying to do he's
trying to fight his fight he's trying to
mock you in his own way he used to only
remember when he thought Damian Meyer I
think he was he was like putting his
hand out helping him up off the ground
he's trying to big brother his opponents
so that and even though he's trying to
like say look come on I have got no fear
from you you can't even hit me like now
mate We're not gonna play that game and
that was the thing is you were probably
one of the most technical Strikers he
ever got in there with a lot of the time
he was in there with tough guys yep like
Don Henderson or a Chris leban or
someone like that but not necessarily
people who could play his game yeah no
for sure and thank you for saying that
because I feel like a lot of the time I
didn't get the respect that I I felt I
was due in terms of my striking ability
but I knew it was good but you're right
a lot of his opponents they were tough
guys they were tough guys and they were
maybe good Grapplers and things like
that but on the feet not the most
skilled it's ironic though because as
much as this should have been one of
your hardest fights it was also one of
your best performances in terms of that
that strike and ability in terms of head
movement yeah fans constantly twitching
and moving like Tyson Fury sort of thing
yep it was a Immaculate as you could be
really thank you thank you no I do
appreciate that and you're right Tyson
Fury that's one thing that stands out to
me when you watch your face constantly
the head movements in the fence it
throws opponents off it really does and
then when you throw the shot you can
land it because they're not expecting it
to come they think you're still playing
that game but it is tiring that's
exactly what I was just about to say is
I would try to exhausted my own sparring
but you the amount of energy the expense
gets to play that game well because for
it to look real yeah it's got to be fast
it's got to be sudden it's going to be
Twitchy do you know what I mean so those
tiny little explosive movements that was
nice from him went to the the thigh and
then came up that was very creative but
not damaging was it no it wasn't
damaging no it was more embarrassing
you prick you know I mean he's a genius
in there I'm such a fan for so long but
yeah as I say at this point now that's
out the window I do think he benefited a
lot from being a South poor actually no
you mention it yeah of course because as
you say also a lot of those people they
weren't the most sophisticated Strikers
that he beat so therefore they were
experience because you know there's just
way more right-handed people in on the
planet how many high level South poles
are you going to find you know Anthony
Joshua found that out against usick like
exactly it [__] you over it really
[__] you over and it changes everything
your combinations are different the
footwork's different it's it's a pain in
the ass here we go
lovely
oh oh
it's a slide bugger though look at that
even when he got dropped it's been with
the up kick brilliant growing a pound
though it looked ferocious yeah yeah we
used to do a lot of work in the garden a
lot of ground apart from the guard you
know you can do a lot of great work
obviously you're at danger of being
submitted but if you're confident in
your submission defense it's a good
place because you can control them side
control and half guard amount you know
they can escape well but full guards
harder to stand up from but yeah this is
uh definitely a good momentum shift for
me personally feel me in control of the
fight and just psychologically and
confidence wise mentally that that was
huge I felt like this was the Anderson
coming out another second round going
all right now I'm trying he leaves the
end of the second round being dropped
taking some deep breaths there though
who you are yeah I'm not surprised
and then
yeah but again hits me with the upkeep
right after getting dropped I mean that
just shows what he's capable of
boom as well
he got me good could you imagine if that
knocked me out that would have been the
greatest knockout of all time gets
[__] dropped and then knocks me out
with an up kick as I'm coming in I would
have been like you bastard yeah so like
now you know not that I'm on autopilot
but I'm like all right this is good
we're in control it's going how I
thought it would just keep doing what
I'm doing just keep with the output keep
with the fence you know the pressure
it's that speed is just not quite
prepared for you yeah yeah my right hand
is looking good but which is surprising
because my right I had so many problems
I'm in my neck I had next showed you
last year I've got to have it again my
right hand is like very slow compared to
my left but I did a lot of work uh with
a Mobility coach for this one it's
[__] very painful in fact oh really
just coming around my house twice a week
and just like manipulate my body and
stretch me out and all that type of
stuff I'm planning to getting a few
injuries just from doing the boxing I'll
do it being like that my right side of
my hip from driving and throughout the
right hand little things like that I'm
like yeah Jesus imagine what Pro
Fighters go through compared to this
still say same same old fight really I'm
doing good in this round again I'm
pressuring him and Landing a lot you
know nothing particularly devastating
but I'm I'm scoring Anderson always had
a great chain uh-huh didn't he could
always take [__] shots I mean you
know is he is he can hit but Anderson
just took his shots and kind of laughed
at him and smiled yeah to be fair to
wide Minnie's a big old boy oh yeah a
big strong block and he had more of that
one shot punch power I think to make him
pay for the the cloning yep but um yeah
I understand that a great chin I think
he's conserving energy I think a part in
this fight it looks to me like he was
aware of your gas tank and didn't want
to match your pace so he sort of let you
take the lead and in his head he
probably thought I can't outwork him so
I've got to hit him with that one shot
yeah yeah
um quality over quantity type thing
please with that there he caught my kick
I went down I just got straight back up
so many fighters they they they're
scared to do that listen you got to get
up you know you might get clipped as you
get up but guess what if you don't
you're gonna get hit more I'll look at
my wife there she's really biting her
fingernails bless her is it weird to
look back now and think of what she was
going through yeah she hated it she
hated it you see some Fighters wise and
they're loving the moment they're loving
the fact that they're all dressed up
they're all dressed up and I saw
somebody's wife that shall remain
nameless recently and the fighter got
knocked out she didn't give a [__] she
was too busy doing selfies and I was
utterly disgusted I was disgusted she
didn't give a [__] she was just there
milking it on the floor and stuff it's a
pretty even round and this is doing a
bit better but I'd still say up until
this point oh he's looking for you know
anything he's coming he knocks my
mouthpiece out yeah and you see when I
turned to Herb Dean and say my
mouthpiece obviously I can say this now
but when I look to the side I couldn't
see how this itself because I'm looking
at the ref because you know yeah I only
have one eye that makes sense now yeah
and then when I looked back he was in
mid-air
bastard look at him the prick ah there's
my mouth holy [__] yeah here we go I've
tried to back off because of the
mouthpiece here you should have tied up
with him really I didn't know there's
only a few seconds just miss a knee here
boom Oh
[__] bro that's right at the end of the
round which in hindsight was was a good
thing because if there was longer left
he wouldn't have stepped in and who
knows maybe he could have hit me with
some more shots
I hit the deal I'm talking to the ref oh
yeah people are like oh you were knocked
out no I actually realized just if you
if we look back just a second yeah pull
it back because you're talking to him
immediately you went out actually that's
exactly what I was I said I'm not out
look because I didn't know either that
you know in the madness I've just been
hit in the face you know
like a temper I mean obviously you're
her but you weren't oh actually I was
down but not out you know and I said uh
yeah I said they're her but I'm not out
and he goes yeah fight's still on I was
like all right I think Anderson near me
was in a hard fight and was trying to
con everyone you think so oh yeah I mean
if I'm included they're telling him no
he he knew he knew he is yeah he wasn't
enjoying that fight and in the confusion
here I don't get a cup man and it opened
up the knee Hitman there was about four
cuts that it opened up made for a good
not many fighters get a picture like
that though where you're like yeah
dripping everything
that's a fight you want to have these
kind of fights where you show adversity
makes it makes a better story you know
yeah of course it's great to go out
there and knock everyone out or whatever
uh and dominate your fights easily but
when you've got to fight through some
adverse team moments like this it's it
makes for a better story it changes the
perception as well like it's another
thing where the fans aren't probably the
fighters are looking at you going [__]
me you've got to kill this
yeah and I think this was the one where
people thought all right maybe he
doesn't quite win this but how does it
how does he how does he actually fare in
the fight and not only winning it but
also battling through a potential
knockout yeah I think it just changed
your whole image yeah I agree with you I
do and obviously for me to sit here
saying things like that it's you you
know you've got to be careful with your
words otherwise you sound like an
[__] no but in one thing something
but I'd be lying if I didn't say that I
had so many positive comments and DMS
and people talking to me and saying man
I changed my opinion after that and this
is up with the heart you showed and blah
blah blah you know stuff like that so
I'm so grateful for everything but you
know even for me as a fan of you like I
was after that fight I was like wow I
knew like I thought I knew him but
you've gone up
thanks bye yeah keeping the balls there
a lot of the time it doesn't necessarily
hurt the balls because you've got a cup
on but it's it's still the thing
thudding into your groin area you know
like the out the outline of the cup goes
putting into your groin it still hurts
you know considering like what a new
year took in the end of the last round
you are going for him here there's no
way yeah no I know yeah okay no you must
have cleared the cobwebs pretty quickly
yeah I was just fighting on instincts at
this point yeah I don't remember any of
it whatsoever I have zero recollection
but that's after the knee you can't
really remember or even the whole fight
yeah I do remember some of round one and
two yeah but after this third round
after that third round I um I was just
an autopilot really just but but the
fights are often like that's because of
the adrenaline oh absolutely a lot of
the time I'd have fights in my early
career where I was so you know high on
adrenaline I wouldn't have a clue what
happened I'd have to watch it back
you know what I mean the way you used to
fight as well like a [__] mad man on
your early fights you just come out
raging exactly and that's what Perillo
changed as well you can fire a lot of
people like that because I used to think
if I get mad and angry and you know I'm
a real Force to do reckon with and you
know but I guess guys I can't as a
silver you can't fight like that you got
to be calm you're going to be reacting
for the right reasons not out of emotion
and ultimately what Anderson was the
best that was was beating someone into
over committing and make them pay and
yeah just didn't do that your
positioning
the way you're sort of edging forward
because there's a number of rule there's
like a little dancing fighting because
you generally want to maintain a certain
distance if you step forward they'll
step back if they step forward you step
back you know what I mean but it's like
an unconscious thing that you do but you
slowly pressure them forward and when
they get to the fence they've got
nowhere nowhere they can back off and
then from there put the combinations
together his Judgment of distance was
one of the best in MMA and you actually
were a level above in this fight in my
opinion considering I had zero depth
perceptions how [__] weird is that
it's no I know because like even now
like sometimes nothing I've got to grab
a drink and I miss it the first couple
of times and then I'll get it on the
third hold on that was a little all
right fair enough fair enough it happens
I think part of this was him tiring as
well yeah no no I I do think so I mean
who knows I mean it was a little poke in
the eye to be fair he's kicking off
though isn't he's complaining vigorously
about it sadly it is it does happen on
occasion and when you're throwing them
out of hands that we we are and I'm
blind and I'm [__] covered in blood I
think for him mentally as well law at
one point he he might have thought he'd
gotten away with you know you being the
dominant fighter and them just getting
up to jail in that third round yeah then
he's got to come and keep fighting you
and it's like oh for [__] yep yeah no no
no you're right will not go away where's
the pressure and it's the realization
that hold on a minute [__] you know
this isn't going to plan yeah I mean I'm
the one covered in blood from that knee
but it still does yeah a lot of good
movements head fakes yeah even though
your face is like that you're fighting
you look fresh yeah yeah that's your
cardio though you've always had an
amazing card it's the most important
thing to have it doesn't matter how good
you are once you get tired you're
screwed absolutely screwed the best fire
in the world if you've got no gas
it makes a coward out of everyone it
really does so I learned that a long
time ago in my career I had a kickboxing
fight eight rounds I didn't train for it
I got offered it last minute and for the
first four rounds I tried to kill the
guy and beat the crap out of him the
next four rounds I was dead and this guy
just [__] batted me for four rounds
it was horrible and I thought I never
want to go through that again did you
see a sense of urgency on him now
because he's like hold on a minute he's
probably got one out of these four
rounds it pisses me and that was a nice
elbow attempt shows how dangerous he is
I love people say oh silver was robbed
Hometown Jersey City wiping the blood
out my eyes there obviously I've only
got one so the blood going in the eye is
an issue nice little Superman punch I
mean I've definitely got I got round one
definitely got round two and I got round
four there that's a good shot so three
three one coming into this one he gets
the fifth round he has some good shots
he has some good moments this is the
thing he he only landed right at the end
of that round you pretty much I would
say dominated the exchanges yeah no I
did I did in that round there if you're
if you're a dumb judge you could be
convinced that I think and I don't know
maybe because he was like on the offense
at the end but you outlanded him so much
in that photo oh 100 he had a couple of
good shots right at the end that was it
you know the cardio thing yeah uh how
did you get so good because I'm actually
trying to boost me cardio people always
ask me you know like there's some kind
of secret you know and I I was never an
athlete at school or nothing I I wasn't
you know but I ended up with a heart
rate of like 34 BPM because I would just
work my [__] ass myself and I would
over train a lot to be honest but
anything I did I did with intensity I
would run a lot and a lot of intervals
so like if I go for a run on the street
I'd say right that lamp post that I'm
gonna Sprint to that one and then I'll
jog slowly to the next one to be covered
because that's how my fight is a fight
is you know you like this and then
explode and then and then you Coast it
for a second then you explode so you're
just gonna get your body used to doing
that so I would Sprint to one lamp post
jog to the other Sprint to one jug to
the other fight like I think they call
it yeah which is a weird name for a
style to run it
this is a violent round this site yeah
you get some nice [__] here and he's
feeling the pressure that's why he's
like crap do you feel the energy
um in terms of loss from blood loss I
don't think so I don't think so no the
energy I do feel is the crowd you know I
mean that's why you know that's why they
wheeled me on through this fight in that
fourth round as well it's just
impossible you can't give up when you've
got 20 000 people not all of them but a
lot of them all cheering and so
passionately supporting you it's like
well I've got to I owe it to these
people you know I owe it to myself of
course but you can't remember some great
shots there
[__] porn on oh
yeah front kick yeah front kick to the
face the one that sparked Vito didn't
put me down here did it I mean it just
stumbled here really it didn't even yeah
I felt it though he's trying to look at
the state of that face holy [__] off
Becca still biting the nails bless you
know it is how how fresh you look in
this fifth round for after everything
that had gone on and Anderson to be fair
yeah I see like top level boxers who
don't look this fresh after 25 minutes
of fighting you know and that always
kind of annoys me it it does is like
you're a professional fighter do your
job fulfill your obligations I have very
very limited sympathy for when people do
not make way too it it I find it very
disrespectful there's only two things
you can control you can't control that
you're gonna win but you can show up on
way in shape if you can't [__] go
hard for the full time then you don't
deserve to call yourself a pro do the
work do the preparation look at back on
a feed blast almost makes me cry every
time I see my wife on that it's weird
it's a weird emotion anytime I see my
kids are my wife it's nice that you
brought them into the octagonist as much
as you did though I I always tried even
when I won the belt they weren't going
to let them in so God was like no get
the [__] out the way I've just walked
the world title right one 90 seconds
I'll try for cheeky takedown
it would have been handy if I got it
there because I needed it and this it
was always hard to take down though we
did a lot of wrestling in this count
because that was obviously part of the
game plan but I think that was the first
takedown attempt to try you know we need
shitloads of wrestling you know what I
mean I'm not right he's [__] sadness
himself and we'll mix it a few takedowns
worked hard with the wrestling coach
paid him a fortune tried one takedown in
the fifth round but to be honest I was
the stand-up was going well for you it
was great it was going well I didn't
feel the need for it yeah the blood
always makes it look worse because
people always say oh look at him at the
end and look at Anderson it's clear who
won so well no that's not what I know
it's not how it works he landed one good
[__] knee and it opened all them Cuts
yeah he knew he didn't win that he knew
my corner was like no you've got that
three rounds for two one two and four
all day long and obviously I was
inclined to agree with them but until
you get your hand raised and I remember
because for me this was such an
important one because I knew the
narrative I knew what people said so
Biscuit's good but he always loses the
big ones this was Mitchell trying to
dispel that myth and show that I can
Prevail in those big moments yeah to
have a win over Anderson Silva who is
the goat by a lot of people's
estimations is you beat him at a time
where no one thought you were going to
beat him yeah I think that spoke even
more volumes yeah and again I'm not
trying to pick myself up but a lot of
people say oh yeah but Anderson wasn't
in his prime so hold on a minute he'd be
beaten by Weidman that was it you'd lost
one fight in like 10 years yeah it lost
one fight and then and by the way I was
almost [__] 40 myself yeah and I'd
[__] eye yeah
I was far from my Prime look if you
can't get your props for beating
Anderson Silva after you just only lost
one fire yeah no then you're never gonna
get it oh that wasn't Prime understand
maybe he wasn't the champ but he'd only
been beat off Wyman how many times do
you beat Anderson yeah look at that yes
the water goes everywhere I mean this oh
God the feeling I mean this is what you
miss there's no better feeling in the
world than that when the announced your
name you jump on top of the cage the
crowd are going wild I mean look at that
I mean it just meant so much to me I
mean I started bawling like a [__]
in a minute you know it is an emotional
Journey it's a very emotional Journey
not only the fact the training camp
everything you go through the sacrifices
obviously my mom and my family down
there I ran in there to see Rebecca but
my mom was there first and my mom always
mentions and he came to see me I'm like
well I was looking for my wife Drive
behind you but of course I wanted to see
my mom as well and my mom when I hooked
her there I got blood on her jacket
which I [__] paid for by the way but
but she was bitching about it afterwards
Michael Michael you got blood over a new
jacket that didn't come out I'm like
well I bought it so shut up I love you
Mum everybody here thank you from the
bottom of my heart if you wanted to you
I wouldn't be here now thank you all I I
always said this I hope people never
think that I was just like saying it for
the sake nobody tells me okay good
you're always because it did every time
and still to this day you know what I
mean like we had this premiere on Monday
and there's [__] tons of people
showed up do you know what I mean it
just blows my mind you know and I'm so
grateful for it because I know I've had
my ups and downs you know and I've I've
done a few things that I regret and I've
said a few things that I regret but
they've stuck with me nobody wrapped the
UK like you ever did and and since
nobody has been we we've got fighters
but obviously they've all got their own
style but you are someone who really
literally put the UK on your back and
made a thing of it more than more than
anyone else ever did really yeah well
thank you I mean I mean I I had a long
career so I was able to do it for a long
time you know I was wiping the blood off
as I was little that's a dig say look at
him there's no blood for me I mean yeah
I I I respected the guy now then we saw
each other afterwards my wife's got this
great picture uh we were both getting
stitched up I was in like one section
until like you know like green curtains
around you like they have in a hospital
and on the other side of it I didn't
know on the other side of the curtain
Anderson was there and he was getting
stitched up and then I was like what the
[__] and I'm just like kind of moved the
curtain we shook hands through the
curtain and Rebecca got a picture of it
it's a cool shot I'm there covered in
blood and we're just shaking ass through
the curtain it's a good one
we have said at UFC tonight and all
around the UFC when is bisbane gonna get
his shot
this fight here I felt amazing is this
is this the title fight it is certainly
is mate felt so good because I always
over trained always this time I didn't
have the ability to do that every time I
always looked for my wife every time I
always went out and gave her a kiss
where look I'm looking for her like
where is she I've got a bit of a thing
for you and your family like you ah like
you know because because I've seen like
I've seen columns Yeah Yeah from being a
little baby boy when he was on your
shoulder yeah yeah now he's a [__]
grown man to see
um a family from England go out there
and live in L.A and then having a lovely
life the stories of you in living in a
car at one point yeah yeah it's like
it's the rocky story really yeah what
we're talking about yeah yeah I guess in
some ways but yeah but right here I'm
very calm and that was one thing Jason
works on for years and one of my
favorite moments is a minute in a minute
when we go to touch gloves and he's like
no touch no touch and I'm not sure if so
it does a little bit on camera he says
no to I said and as I'm going back and
this shows how Karma was I'm like no
church no touch I'll touch you in a
second [__] but the fact I was
making joke shows I was calm you know
and here he is he was too calm far too
come yeah I mean he was good and he was
a dominant champion and he was smoking
everybody but he was doing it with a
really good blend of grappling and stand
up and he got to a point where like you
see him jigging his shoulders a bit
there yeah Muhammad Ali yes like a [__]
downstairs
he's like he got too confident too
big-headed and that's the gift in the
curse he's an athletic specimen I mean
he was a professional Surfer he was a
almost professional skateboarder he
could do any sport he won he's got
insane coordination I mean I see him in
the gym sometimes now and he's a he's a
talented guy ironically you're this is
funny though he's biggest fault yeah
well he's a handsome Buster he can't
have everything exactly you know what I
mean the guy was a model for foxy I know
I know he's all right though I shouldn't
say that he's all right I'm saying that
against this easy well I know he's a top
lad I've seen you guys had a photo
together yeah no he's all right everyone
thinks you've still got this beef we
don't have beef you know look at his
face there that that fish it's like this
is a chore yeah it's like oh god I've
got to go and beat this guy again ever
that was his whole demeanor is all right
let me just get this out of the way so I
can go back to living my life yeah times
will be my commands at all times I want
you to fight clean Fight Hard you want
to touch him down go ahead good luck to
both of you
touching a second [__] but he
did touch go upstairs no church no
church and then he touches I assume he
meant when you first come out oh right
okay that never dawned on me after all
these years you break you're making me
look down now yeah look at him he's he's
literally carrying himself like Floyd
Mayweather here he's trying too hard to
look like that so for this one here I
mean you can see I'm swinging
more aggressively because going five
rounds may or may not have been in my
favor because yeah you know not a short
short notice didn't have a full cam I
didn't feel bad cardio wise but it
wasn't fantastic so I'm like if I'm
gonna win I gotta get him out of there I
wish I'd have done that earlier in my
career I was like I just [__] swing
that was a problem actually though
because as I became more technical you
start overthinking it and like you lose
a bit of that raw aggression you know
what I mean you come a little more
cerebral in your approach you could have
that good blend so the idea was
obviously use that right hand to set up
the left hook you know so pretty little
even said I was like using it as a job
but I can see how that would help you
with the momentum you know yeah when you
twist yeah
so he just thinks he can walk you down
yeah of course you should never
underestimate anybody like that got
London yeah that was the that was the
precursor yeah
I got his attention again you did so
well with self-belief in regards to this
fight like having a loss against the sky
yeah you didn't let it affect you at all
mentally here well I do because in the
first fight I could hardly see but I
mean I only had one eye but I cut open
in my eye and I was like I know I can do
better than that because I I couldn't
see I was wiping my eye and then I could
see then blood will go in I couldn't see
it and wipe it again I remember getting
up for this fight at like three oh
really yeah oh I I don't miss those days
my God they used to be a pain in the ass
I was like alone in the house and all of
a sudden I'm jumping around it like four
or five A.M
silver fights and I go to bed at like
five six in the morning my wife would
wake up and say how was it I was [__]
prick knocked him out in 30 seconds now
why did I stay up all night here he
comes
get [__] down and then he will I mean
they're good shots his [__] heads
flopping about that I love seeing this
if I'm honest I might have said this
before but when I jumped on the cage
there and I turned around I said [__]
you it wasn't like they weren't gonna
let it like no I'm like my [__]
family's coming in here but I wasn't to
say [__] you to him I would say [__] you
to everyone that ever doubted oh
absolutely do you know what I mean
because there was a lot of them
look on his face oh good and the bit
when he does that
best oh this is the bit gets me every
time ah
oh God that made it all worth it
everything everything I went through all
the sacrifice all the pain all the
surgeries all the uh the ups and downs
the the the [__] I had to put up with
you know made it all worth it in the end
I mean it would have been great anyway
because I did it to earn a livid here we
go boom boom I couldn't believe it when
he went down when I was I was like oh
[__] and then he gets back up on that ho
ho ho no you don't buddy bomb over the
top again but right now I was like stay
out of his guard he's got good Jiu Jitsu
and I'm like [__] that let's just crack
him look good yeah yeah yeah get down
proven people wrong people said about
your power yeah first round knockout of
a guy who hadn't had looked unbeatable
yeah you know yeah yeah smoked on that
do you know what I mean uh and you know
because when I went around the cage I
gave him a fist bump but we shook hands
and then I was celebrating I went around
a second time and I went to shake his
hand again and he goes I've already
shaken your hand I've already shaking
your hand so then that's when Michael
Bishop the Dicker came out oh really you
you want to be a dick I said sorry buddy
I said you you've been knocked out Luke
you've been knocked out don't worry
you'll come to in a minute and I'm like
I said by the way you're in a cage
you're in an octagon I said don't worry
though I said you're gonna come back in
a minute [__] me it's bad enough you've
just took his world title oh yeah but
he's funny he's refusing to shape I know
he refusing to shave my hands all right
Paul well you know now I'm gonna look at
DC bless him do you say you knew what
you [__] didn't respect them I mean
that felt good job
you got the belt at home yeah oh I got
two of them yeah
I'm like on the walls or anything like
that though they're just in a little
unit you can see him mom but the very
very subtle a champ uh Callum bless him
ah God that was such a special moment so
incredible and then I say the dumbest
[__] right now no no listen to this
listen to this though I started fighting
when I came out of my mother really ever
since I came out of my mother I meant I
was born a fighter I painted an image of
me exiting my mother's vagina oh look at
Callum bless him you look so happy mom
he starts the champion of the football
oh I know how mental is that oh you're
making me cry mate
ah it was a good finish though weren't
it beautiful that makes it I mean
obviously you you know to become The
champ is amazing but to do it like that
oh man no doubt no doubt Michael thank
you thank you England I don't know what
to say about anybody that needs thanks
thank you oh my God yeah everybody there
needs thanks thank you I love it man I
love it string ascent
that was uh two of my favorite fights
and and also my favorite title win ever
um I'm sitting watching it with a guy
who I grew up watching so I couldn't get
any better than that ah Brian no it's
amazing mate it's always great to talk
to you you know that and thanks for
doing this with me because uh believe me
I've sent them the title one a few times
because it comes up all the time and
anytime I get a chance I'm like yeah
I'll watch them yeah yeah but I haven't
watched a full fight for a long time and
the end this is silver fight I I mean I
have watched it of course but I I can't
remember when the last time I sat down
and actually watched it five rounds and
even the walkouts and everything I don't
think I've ever done that so yeah no I
really enjoyed it it was a nice trip
down memory lane because in my house
it's the way I like it I get no respect
do you know what I mean yeah everyone
yeah I get nothing but [__] and abuse
but that's the culture I've cultivated
you know what I mean like my suddenly
related to you exactly I thought Lucas
has never seen any of my fights he's not
interested at all yeah one day it's
gonna hit him like well I know there was
one day we were letting bed before he
goes to bed he always comes and gets in
our bed and like sits and you know takes
the piss out of me for a while and I was
flicking through the TV and the Kung Lee
fight was on oh yeah I'm like sun sun
watch this watch this is a good one this
and he was watching he was kind of
disgusted for a minute he goes Dad how
can you do that to another person and
I'm like oh come on and we were watching
it and then like I'm I'm glued on the TV
and then I looked around and he's
slightly going out the room not
interested at all do you know what I
mean and then like going swim in the
swimming pool I thought yeah
I saw you growing up with a [__]
swimming pool how do you think we got
that do you know what I mean my wife
well I'll do commentary or whatever I'm
like did you watch what did you think
you know she's like oh no I didn't see
it I said you were at home she's like
yeah I'm cooking dinner dinner oh you
know so but that's great that's what you
want uh don't forget Mike's got a
channel that's growing rapidly be sure
to subscribe to that thank you one of my
most watched YouTube channels easily uh
it's great content uh hit that like
button subscribe thanks for watching and
we'll see us later
everything